he's a Hall of Famer NBA on TNT analyst
Charles Barkley he's an Arizona resident
he joins us now how do you feel about
your Arizona Cardinals there Chuck you
know it's a decision it's a job a job
decision if you go with the young fella
with the number-one draft pick if he
works out you keep your job if it
doesn't work out you don't get fired
plain and simple but I go back to when
you were being drafted and people
weren't sure how you would fit in like
we profile all the time we we profile in
all walks of life here but they had
nobody to compare you to if you were
coming out now would you have a would
you go higher in the draft would we know
more about you and have the comps and
therefore we'd go okay we know how to we
know where we can put him in plug him in
you know I don't know the answer that
question but I think you say listen
those guys that's why you know the
general managers normally get breaks
because they normally get to hire two or
three coaches before people realize the
gym is the problem you know that I think
being a gym is probably the safest job
than always for it because you'd like I
said you get to hired and fire like two
or three coaches before people realize
you don't want making these decisions so
you make the decision if it doesn't work
out you know that that's why you get
paid all that money damn and I'll tell
you what it's a big loss Arizona I mean
a few draft Kyler's and it doesn't work
out you you deserve to get fired but you
got to do something with Rosen also I
mean he's only been there for one year
and they didn't have a lot of weapons so
that's such a small sample size but like
I say if you draft a young fellow from
Oklahoma and it doesn't work out you got
to get fire playing a simple if Zion
Williamson was coming out 15 years ago
20 years ago would we look at him
differently than we do now in today's
NBA well I think he would have been a
much better player in my day because
he's a tweener he's a three four kind of
like myself and you just you know you
played the game on talent and
physicality
I think he'd have been a much better
player of my day like I think it'll be a
lot harder for me to play in the NBA
today chasing those threes and fours
around out on the floor the way the NBA
structured today
I mean I'm smart enough to know that
like you know Zions gonna be a 304
obviously you know he's got to be he's
gonna have an advantage against some
threes be a disadvantage against some
force but I think he would have been a
much better player of my day like I
wouldn't have been as good a player
today the way they played a game today
would you take him number one I like to
kid Barrett personally I think scored is
a is a you know that's that's what
you've got to do in the NBA game today
I think Jean is a very very talented kid
like I said my biggest concern is what
position he's gonna play in people said
was positional is basketball not on not
on one end of the floor is not when
you're trying to chase a three around or
four around when he who if the guy's
smart he will post up but I would take I
probably take Barrett number one in my
personal opinion did you think the NBA
had to find Russell Westbrook in that
situation in Utah yes and I think listen
most our fans are fantastic fantastic
but that's about 10% that you you know
that are just bad people oh I am never
watching soccer again let me take my
given soccer every opportunity into
America suck that except for the women
the women are great but they're being
suck at it but let me tell you something
my dream come true
would be for a fan to come out on the
field and hit me that would be like my
dream come true and limitation would
piss me off number-one homeboy just
flopped but also the other team didn't
be down on his back later
so that was Aston Villa the other
Jack Grealish I thinks his name he got
hit a bailout beer okay whoo I never
like I like him now we're cool but I
know like if a fan hit Bamboula bill and
beer we're in the same fraternity I've
got to I can't let a fan
come on a quarter hit him and so those
huh kids I mean those soccer players who
let that man get hit and then this dude
is kissing to the crowd he would have
been kissing to the crowd if I if I had
to got my hands on him that's my dream
come true for a fan to hit me so what
you're saying is if Bill Laimbeer was
attacked by a fan and you were playing
on the court should beat the hell out of
that spectator
yeah we're all in the same fraternity I
don't wish any ill toward any NBA player
but if somebody had Bill Laimbeer just
out of being in the Brotherhood
we shall whoop the hell out of that fan
and when that soccer player number one
he's staying on the ground and these
other guys didn't his teammates didn't
even beat his guy down
that pisses me off so bad so I am
officially boycotting soccer forever
he's Charles Barkley the Hall of Famer
NBA on TNT analyst James Dolan had a
little confrontation with the fan and
the fan just said hey sell the team
typical Dolan overreacting
unnecessary uncalled for God got
thin-skinned man I mean he said he
hasn't done a good job with the team and
listen I've heard fans say 10 times
worse than that but for him to do that
that's that's just that's typical Dolan
will you also talk say there's one thing
though Russell has to have thicker skin
once you get that reputation where fans
know dick and irritates you by saying
something to you you got to ignore Dan
because then it becomes a contest who
can light your fuse and then you get
away from your game plan so as much as I
Russell Russell's got to have thicker
skin and ignore that stuff that's now
everybody's gonna be saying stuff just
to piss him off
yeah but you know that there's certain
words that are said and it's go time
like just go time what's gonna happen
when you go you're gonna hurt one of
these fans and you go you're gonna be in
jail and you're gonna be broke
hey listen first of all there's go words
everybody knows there go words but if
you go and beat one of these people up
and hurt them you're gonna be in jail
and you gonna be poor and let me tell
you our black and poor don't work in any
space Columbia Canada it don't work
anywhere so you have to let that stuff
go listen what dead now you know I've
been at risk I take four time for
hitting fans I was wrong I'm more mature
now at the time I hit them they deserve
to be hit but I'm 50 section now I was
wrong you got to be able to walk away I
mean because that day first of all
they're not they don't want to fight you
they can't beat you they want to upset
you and sue you I mean that's the only
thing they're trying to do I have to
like say I was wrong when I did it I
don't regret doing it but I was wrong
every man enough to admit when you're
wrong but at the time they deserved it
but I'm older now I got to walk away now
how many second cost you oh well going
to jail always sucks it didn't cost me a
time because I was found not guilty
every one time I ever felt really bad
was a god Indiana a guy in Indiana I
popped him one good time but he deserved
it that we were getting beat by 40 and I
would he was said right beside the [ __ ]
I was your man y'all about for to let it
go
he keeps chirping at her but I was young
man you keep tripping I'm a clock yet
and he kept turbine I clocked him I was
wrong but he deserved it he didn't warn
him at this point
for tea with them we getting our ass
kicked
let it go brother there's no need to be
screaming at me I'm sitting on a [ __ ]
we've thrown up the white flag let it go
you said to Sports Illustrated that
Kyrie and KD can't handle New York
they're too sensitive I don't think they
can I think both you know Katie is a
great great player Kyrie is a good
player I don't know if you know damn
part of our job is to deal with the
press first got a job to do and they say
they deserve a lot of responsibility for
the stuff that's going on this year they
should have said from day one training
camp hey I'm not going out for any free
agent questions any free agent questions
and then somebody asked you the question
just say next question
put it next six seven months but I think
both of them are really sensitive and I
think they would have a tough time
playing in New York that's just my
personal opinion hey ash I think they
both great guys I think everybody know
they're great guys but I think everybody
know they got thinner skin than Flat
Stanley
[Laughter]
do you understand the Lakers game plan
going into next season
no the licorice truth is things are from
day one and then you go back and look at
my tape from October I said what are the
liquors doing are they trying to make
the playoff bring it in all these old
guys
or they trying to figure out if the
young guys can play they had no game
plan from day one listen dad you you got
to make a choice is that we're trying to
grow these young guys are we trying to
make the playoffs you can't have both
they put Luke Walton in a situation
where he was going to fail he was going
to fail no matter what because like I
say and it's not brain surgery I don't
understand listen you got some really
good young players so let them see who
you want to keep and who you want to
trade but when you bring in Rondo
Beasley last JaVale you knew those young
guys you're going to number one you're
going to take their planned time and
they got off to a good start that was
the softest part of a schedule and then
LeBron got hurt and anything went out of
whack but it
doomed from the beginning and he had no
plan and now they got to pay for it I
just if I'm a free agent I don't want to
go into this situation you know I just I
wouldn't know I think the biggest thing
I think you know Kevin Durant used to
work toxic toxic I'm not sure toxic is
the right word but I think what you have
to understand if you go there if you
watch the LeBron for the last X amount
of years when LeBron wins he's the next
better than Michael Jordan he's the
greatest thing in the world but when
they lose everybody around him all the
players stuck in a culture suck and if
you're a free agent you have to accept
that I mean go back every year first of
all the brother is amazing I'm not
talking about about LeBron I know by the
time it goes over there way tomorrow I'm
talking about about LeBron but you have
to understand like think about every
year he's played in Cleveland
or whatever every time he they win he's
the greatest thing which he's great but
every time they lose everybody around
him sucks including the coach and you
see the same thing happening in LA
it happened in Cleveland so now if I'm a
free agent I'm like wait I'm not gonna
get any credit but if we lose I'm gonna
get to blame I can go just three or
three other teams that got max likes and
I don't have near the pressure upon me
so I think that's what's going to be the
most interesting dynamic this summer
with the Lakers I did I talked to
Candice Parker last week and I said
could she beat you one-on-one and she
said is that even a question on your
show cuz I don't want them women beat on
my door this is this is just basketball
it's just two basketballs what I mean
that's all this is
you gonna make me be sexist Dan a woman
can't beat me on a sport just stop it in
any sport any sport oh okay wait wait
let's take golf out of this yes a woman
can't beat me in golf with sure what
a regular person about an LPGA Pro but
like some regular woman on the street
are you saying Candace Parker would beat
you one-on-one Chuck Dan Chuck let's
raise some money for charity let me go
hey listen I love working with Candace
she's very times does offense I the job
but a woman can't beat men a sport dan
stop it
damn Charles Candace Parker is in shape
is young she's good she's a baller you
know we're gonna play half-court yeah
it's one-on-one we've asked the police
to back in the day you played some you
know that half way full court thing
sideways no no no we're not doing this
okay she can't beat me down she can't
believe that I insulted her when I even
asked the question there it's different
it's if different if she played against
Shaq could she beat Kenny could she beat
Ernie all right well I will see if we
can set this up you were you against
Candace wait are you just gonna just
back her in is that what your game plan
is they might call offensive fouls on
you Charles it's today's my god that's
why when I look at Hardin and see what
he does and when Phil Jackson said a
couple years ago you know
Mike would have averaged Jordan would
have averaged 45 a game in today's NBA
and I totally agree with that you know
Dan I people looked at me last year I
said James Harden is the greatest
offensive player on my hair ever seen
and then you know and Kenny came at me
he said what about Michael and Kobe I
says in today's games and James ability
to shoot the three I think James and I
said Iceman Gervin a Bernard King those
are probably four greatest scorers I've
ever seen but don't wanna leave out
Kevin Durant and guys like that but
James Hart and today's game with
instability shooter 3 and put the ball
down I think he's the greatest offensive
player that I've seen and that's
counting Michael and Kobe but they
played during the day when you can beat
the hell out of people but in today's
game you have to give James his credit
he's the greatest off as a player I
might have ever seen yeah I'm there with
you I actually feel like he's underrated
or underappreciated because he's a great
three-point shooter and he invites
contact he can get to the hoop there's
not many scores who can do everything
that he does and I marvel at him when I
watch him I everybody's like oh he's a
gunner well he was gunning because they
had to stay and play that was the only
offense they had when he had the
injuries but you know I'm there with you
I think Harden will go down in history
is you know one of the top five scores
of all time as far as not points wise
you know what's interesting I would be
curious to see where he's at because if
you look at you know the Brian obviously
just past Michael I want our wonder
where James is on the all-time list so
if he keep a virgin 30-ish for another
five to seven years I mean he's got to
be getting way up on the list yeah I
mean I mean I many points James guy for
his career you have yeah one of the
dentists clicked out of year right quick
no they can't do it that quickly see
that's the difference between the TMT I
guess
hold on yes Pauline James Harden 18100
16 points
I mean Oh bad so he and he'll probably
get he'll be at 20 21 21 22 in the next
year and he's 29 so he's got he got at
least five more years we gonna have it's
over 30 yeah I mean 35 32 35 that's
pretty good
hey always great to talk to you get in
better shape cuz Candace Parker's coming
for you Thank You Charles
that's Charles Barkley Hall of Famer if
you missed any of our interviews from
the mercedes-amg man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app watch and listen from
inside the mercedes-amg man cave
mercedes-amg driving performance for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]